It is September 1991.
I'm wearing my new
green and white uniform,
and I show up to my second grade class
with both excitement and trepidation.
It should have been a walk in the park,
but my first grade year
was disrupted by a coup d’état,
which was a culmination
of a 17-year civil war in Ethiopia.
As a second grader,
I was now emerging back into the world
after months of lockdown.
What should have been this euphoric moment
to reunite with my friends,
however, became one
of the most haunting moments of my life,
shaping both my worldview
and my future life's work.
You see, in my prior six years of life,
up until this point,
I had no idea
that I was a multiethnic individual
in the Ethiopian context.
I knew my parents
belonged to different ethnic tribes,
but I had not assigned meaning
to these labels.
But that formative September,
I began to realize
the political significance
of each of my identities
as systematically orchestrated
by the new ruling government.
So as any child trying to fit in
and avoid bullying,
I began the journey of claiming
one ethnic identity, my father's,
and hiding the other, my mother's.
I spent my entire childhood
navigating this identity minefield.
Eventually, at 13, I immigrated to the US.
And let me tell you what I learned.
Exclusion -- it's global.
You see, whether
in a quasidemocracy like Ethiopia
or a developed one like the United States,
we are confronted with the ideology
of both inclusion and othering.
So the question becomes,
how do we build societies
that are both functional and inclusive?
This is a question I've been wrestling
with since second grade.
I strongly believe
the answer is democracy.
This is not to say democracy
as we have it today is perfect.
In fact, it is struggling in so many ways,
including in being effective
and representative.
However, with its inherent values
of individual choice and collective voice,
democracy is the most compelling vision
we have for self-governance.
So straightening democracy
has become my life's work.
In 2022, I founded the nonpartisan,
nonprofit organization Keseb
to address two challenges
facing democracy:
the rise of authoritarianism
and the need to reimagine democracy.
These are enormous challenges
that I'm talking about,
and addressing them requires
a global pro-democracy movement.
So how do we do it?
How do we build this movement?
I believe we need to make
democracy inspiring.
We need to accelerate
the pace of innovation
in the pro-democracy movement,
and we as a global community
need to come together
to embrace our interconnectedness.
I'll explain what I mean.
Let's start with: make democracy
inspiring and relevant.
For a few decades now,
democracy has been in crisis.
We have to ask, why is this happening?
In my work, we have found
four key drivers:
economic change and inequality;
dysfunctional and unregulated
information ecosystems;
rapid demographic changes;
and finally, the interplay
between opportunistic populist leaders
and political elites.
Collectively, these forces are driving
the crisis of democracy globally.
This has left many people
feeling disillusioned
and thus more susceptible to manipulation
by authoritarian narratives,
activating what researchers call
the “authoritarian reflex,”
which is really about people's desire
for answers and security.
Authoritarian leaders are exploiting this
by offering very simplistic
and often ethnonationalist
and malinformed solutions
to address our everyday challenges,
like building a wall to promote security.
And unfortunately, they're succeeding.
To make democracy inspiring,
we have to tell a better story
about democracy.
Let me ask you this.
Have you ever found yourself
waking up before sunrise,
thinking about the state of democracy?
(Laughter)
No? I mean, I do. It's my job.
But I'm sure there are lots of you
who do as well.
But the vast majority of us,
we wake up thinking
about food, our families,
our health, our jobs,
the day-to-day life matters.
Compared to these issues,
often democracy seems so distant.
But it isn't.
It is embedded in everything
that affects our daily life.
We fight authoritarianism
not only through elections,
but also through a compelling
pro-democracy narrative
that is both practical and inspirational.
Practical in that it speaks
to how democracy meets our everyday needs
and inspirational in that it addresses
what political scientists call
the “root ideas.”
Who we are as a people,
what we value, what matters to us.
And we're seeing innovative examples
for how to do this.
In the US, the nonpartisan
media organization PushBlack
promotes civic engagement
through sharing Black history,
presenting information
often people never learned in school.
PushBlack's nine million subscribers
are responsible
for one of the most effective
voter engagement programs in America.
In Israel, before the war,
a historic citizen-led movement
had galvanized people
across the ideological spectrum
to stand up for democratic norms
and institutions.
This has led to the creation
of a new political center
that will impact the future
of both Israel and Palestine.
These are examples
of ordinary people coming together
to create compelling
pro-democracy narratives
that unite communities.
Second, we need to accelerate
the pace of innovation
in the pro-democracy movement.
The battle between autocracy and democracy
is both conceptual and tactical.
It requires offensive
and defensive strategies,
and on this front, the authoritarians
have been quite innovative.
Through effective cross-border learning,
they have developed what scholars call
"The Authoritarian Playbook."
From North America
to Southeast Asia to Europe,
you see this playbook in motion.
It consists of strategies
such as undermining institutions,
spreading disinformation,
exploiting racial
and religious differences,
weaponizing fear,
and stoking political violence.
I call this playbook
the “authoritarian innovation ecosystem,”
because the tactics are not static.
They are continually being perfected
based on wins and losses across the globe.
I'll give you an example.
Election denialism.
In 2020, former US President Donald Trump
catalyzed a movement claiming
the presidential election was stolen.
This led to the January 6, 2021 riots
in Washington, DC,
and continues to define
American politics today.
Soon after that,
Brazil's former president Jair Bolsonaro,
also known as Trump of the Tropics,
started to claim fraud
in his upcoming election
and then refused to acknowledge his loss.
This led to the January 8,
2022 riots in Brasilia,
and similar to the US,
the country remains highly polarized.
So if authoritarians
are learning from each other
and supporting one another,
we have to ask: Why aren’t our best
pro-democracy innovators doing the same?
Currently, the pro-democracy
movement is stymied
because we operate
in silos divided by national borders.
We find ourselves responding to crises
as opposed to preventing them.
But the good news is
that we don't have to start from scratch.
There are pro-democracy innovations
all over the world.
What we need to do is learn from them
and then weave them together globally.
In Brazil, the organization
Pacto pela Democracia
builds cross-partisan coalitions
to protect elections.
Guess what? The American organization
Protect Democracy does the same thing.
Or take Academy
for Future Leaders in France
and Futurelect in South Africa.
Both organizations are working
to train young people
to pursue political office
based on their values.
There are innovative
pro-democracy organizations like these
all over the world.
Most of them don't even know
about each other.
We need strong transnational
learning platforms,
convenings and pro-democracy networks
to enable these democracy champions
to learn from each other
and support one another.
I believe if lessons can be
imported and exported
by the authoritarians
to dismantle democracy,
we can use the same strategy to save it.
Third,
we need to embrace our interconnectedness
as a global community.
I don't need to tell you
how badly polarization is impacting us.
We demonize each other
within borders and across borders.
This is a key component
of the authoritarian playbook.
The reality is that democracies
depend on one another to survive,
just as autocracies do,
which means that we,
as people of different nations
also depend on one another.
We can use this interdependence
to promote oppression or liberation.
We see this throughout history.
For example, concentration camps
were not actually
an invention of Nazi Germany.
They first appeared
in Spanish Cuba and South Africa
long before there was ever an Auschwitz.
Concentration camps
were an exported innovation
for oppression.
On the other side of the spectrum,
civil disobedience
that served as the anchor strategy
for the US civil rights movement
was honed by the nonviolent movement
in India against British rule.
An example of an imported
innovation for liberation.
Innovation for oppression,
or innovation for liberation:
it is up to us to choose.
In today’s political discourse,
isolationism is often presented
as a solution to our many problems.
But we know that's not the answer.
We can be locally rooted
and globally connected.
We can be proud of our unique
national identity and culture
without disparaging another.
The authoritarians want us to believe
that problem is the other.
I have been the other.
In Ethiopia, in the US and most places
I've ever visited or lived in.
But I also know what it feels like
to be a part of something,
a part of a collective
that is working towards
a common and unifying vision,
a better world.
Our future lies in our togetherness,
not in our separation
within our countries and across borders.
In this century, I believe
we can be imaginative and audacious
about what is possible.
From Addis to Atlanta,
from Brasilia to Berlin,
from Jakarta to Jerusalem.
This is our moment, for all of us,
not only for professional
democracy advocates like me,
but for every single one of us
to come together and build
a truly global pro-democracy movement.
Thank you.
(Applause)